der ultimative karriere boost steht fest
als top checker muss man heute berater
für ministerien werden
doch wie ich hole mir entgeht power
tipps von einem consulting genie er ist
einer der top berater der brüsseler und
berliner politszene doktor andreas
geiger was brauche ich um ein richtiger
top berater zu sein haben wir haben
völlig ungerechtfertigt das
selbstbewusstsein ja das bringt mit war
so dass das alles wirklich dass das ist
ja bei der heute show im grundwasser das
ist klar
wie kann ich das anstellen wenn ich
jemanden berater sein ministerium
berater das was ich mich nicht so weit
aus dem fenster hängen und und irgendwie
inhaltlich festlegen weil das geht ja
alles auch den bach runtergehen und so
unter umständen wird schlecht läuft es
richtig gut läuft bin ich auch noch
schulter das ist eine katastrophe sie
sollten immer schauen dass sie nicht
alleiniger berater dieses ministeriums
sind
das ist immer noch ein paar anderen
jugendlichen neben bereichen unterwegs
sein kann danach hat bleiben die hätten
rhein gefischt oder hier hätten ähnlich
rechtzeitig und wer das ist ein bisschen
silva spill over effekt dass auch schön
dass das heißt also wenn man wenn man
sagt also mein mann mein bereich die
arschkarte weiter genau wenn berater
wissen wie man politik machen warum
machen sie es eigentlich dann nicht
einfach selber und gehen die politik
verdient nur zu wenig starkes argument
deswegen auf nach berlin
die ministerien brauchen meinen
sachverstand doch leider gibt es
notorische miesmacher die uns berater
kritisch sehen wie die linke gesine
lötzsch oder tobias lindner natürlich
von den grünen dagegen war einfach meine
karte geben hier
ich bin von der gsi monster wie die
basterds consulting es ist manchmal
firma ich bin jetzt berater geworden
[Musik]
sebastian gott sei dank die
hauptkompetenz der berater besteht der
im folgenden zu erklären das problem ist
super komplex und ich brauche den
nächsten beratervertrag und für die
nächsten beratervertrag braucht noch
viel viel mehr geld ich habe mich auch
für diesen job und für deutschland und
dann kommen sie daher und sagen mir geht
es nur ums geld
ich habe hier das passende wird dazu
dass wir die berater republik das sind
die berater und das sind die
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler der
berater versucht zwar noch ein bisschen
was dran zu lassen an dem steuerzahler
mitarbeiter zahlt aber sie sehen das
missverhältnis sagen sie als vollkommen
falsch interpretiert sie kennen diese
fische die ihre babys im maul brüter
nennt man sie also ihre babys im mund
behalten und so sehen wir uns nämlich
haben sie eine vision für deutschland
eine million ist als 1000 euro am tag
da will ich wie man nicht so was naja
ich brauchen kontakte zu müssen leute
können ja am besten keine ausschreibung
machen wenn sie keine ausschreibungen
grenze hohe tagessätze wir verhandeln
und dann ihr projekt zu müssen das
irgendwie englisch lernen das muss fans
am besten darf niemand verstehen was sie
wirklich tun dann kann auch niemand ihre
ergebnisse sind okay viele minister
haben eine geistige zentralverriegelung
und von daher ist es eigentlich völlig
sinnlos dass ihre die ihre anbieten
von wegen verteidigungsministerium hirai
kam und natürlich stehen ein management
mastermind wie mir alle türen offen ja
schönen tag
kabelka hier von gbc credit buzzard
consulting
ich habe einen termin mit seiner
ministerin von der leyen
meine visitenkarte eine visitenkarte ist
das von rené barth consulting es geht
darum ich möchte ganz gerne den ganzen
laden hier jetzt mal ordentlich durch
beraten weil das ist ja jetzt wirklich
von nöten und ich habe von daher gesehen
auch gehört es gibt eine ganze menge
hier zu verdienen 12.000 cash am tag
sehen sie möchten nicht beraten werden
in den angenehmen tag den möglichen auch
aber ist weil es wird natürlich
konsequenzen haben wenn sie jetzt von
mir nicht beraten werden wollen sie
vielleicht beraten werden sie wollen sie
beraten werden nein warum nicht
sie können alle freunde mit der
einstellung ne also
[Musik]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok
[Musik]
wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße